1,5 millions de pèlerins du monde entier
se sont réunis dimanche à Lisbonne pour
assister à la messe finale des Journées
Mondiales de la Jeunesse présidée par le
pape François cet événement
international réunit tous les deux à
quatre ans la jeunesse catholique autour
du pape de Rome point d'orgue d'une
semaine de festivités la messe de
clôture s'est tenue dans un immense parc
à l'est de la capitale portugaise et a
été diffusé sur des écrans géants une
marée de croyants avait pris les lieux
d'assaut dès samedi après-midi pour
assister à la veillée nocturne qu'elle
est présidé le souverain pour DIF c'est
peu après 20h à bord de sa mythique papa
mobile blanche qui l'a fait son
apparition entourée d'ovation et de
drapeaux de nombreux pays 1,5 millions
de participants c'est l'équivalent de
15% de la population totale du Portugal
réunit en un même lieu un défi
logistique relevé avec succès selon le
super intendant Pedro Moura nous sommes
très satisfaits cela s'est déroulé selon
les prévisions et il n'y a pas eu
d'incident majeurs briller écouter être
sans crainte voici les trois conseils
prodigués par le pape devant la foule
lors de la messe du dimanche il a con
célébré avec 10 000 prêtres 700 évêques
et 30 cardinaux
le jésuite argentin a également prié
pour ceux qui n'ont pas pu venir en
raison des conflits et des guerres
[Musique]
pour l'accueillir
samedi 200000 fidèles s'étaient réunis
au sanctuaire de Fatima dans le centre
du Portugal ou François a fait une
visite éclair pour réciter le chapelet
avec des jeunes malades et handicapés il
a improvisé la quasi-totalité de son
premier discours sans lire son texte
n'évoquant ni la guerre en Ukraine ni la
recherche de la paix de thèmes pourtant
très attendus pour cet étape j'ai prié
pour la paix mais je n'ai pas fait de
publicité à affirmer le pape aux
journalistes dimanche soir au cours de
sa visite la plus longue d'un pape dans
ce pays ibérique le pontife a toutefois
abordé de nombreux thèmes comme
l'écologie les réseaux sociaux ou la
pédocriminalité au sein de l'Église dans
l'avion le ramenant à Rome François qui
est âgé de 86 ans a dit se portait bien
alors que son état de santé avait
suscité des inquiétudes deux mois après
une lourde opération de l'abdomen
il y a plein aussi
c'est sous les acclamations des jeunes
coréens venus nombreux pour l'événement
que le pontife a annoncé le lieu des
prochains JMJ François a déjà visité la
Corée du Sud en 2014 un pays à 30%
chrétien dont 8% sont des catholiques